I'm interested in getting a sauna for sweating sessions.
I'm confused as to whether to buy one with the red light spectrum, 600 nanometers or the
near infrared spectrum, 840 nanometers in the 980 nanometers from each diode, like the
Theresage 360 hazard, one from sauna dot space that claims that their bulb produces a full
spectrum infrared light that mimics the solar spectrum, the one at sauna dot space looks
nice.
OK, so we've talked about this lots and lots of times.
So all these companies that makes us claim their lights are better for one reason or the
other.
The truth is none of them are really giving true infrared, far infrared, near infrared
spectrum technology.
They are just art.
They're a little light source would have to cost $5,000 by itself in order for it to
give true, true infrared spectrum technology.
That in fact, if you buy like our infrared heating unit for breast cancer or liver cancer
or wherever you're going to use it, no light comes out of it because it is under the light
spectrum and step in for a red terminology on it.
So really you're buying a sauna to heat.
Don't forget about all the claims that they make.
I just think honestly, you know, yeah, you're getting a little bit of little bit of these
things.
Just throw those out.
You're not getting any really healing qualities of all that other stuff.
You're buying a sauna to heat your body up so that you sweat.
That's the whole purpose and hopefully maybe even meet your body up so you increase your
internal temperature, you increase your temperature, that would even be great.
But lots of sodas will do any sauna will do that.
So just get one where, you know, it's inexpensive.
Lots of times you could find sodas on Craigslist or Facebook Marketplace because a lot of people
buy sodas and then don't use them and then they just have to get rid of them.
So look on that too.
You just want a sauna that's going to heat up, you know, quickly, unless your lifestyle is
handled, why not?
If it takes 20 minutes to heat up, I'll just go do something and come back and that's fine.
Just, you know, get a sauna that you're going to use, you know, personally, I have a
sauna and I like the ones where my head sticks out because I get a little claustrophobic in
a sauna.
There's nothing to do with the claustrophobic of a space constriction, but it has to do with
I can't feel like I can't breathe and it has partly as you with my sinus issues.
So I like my head exposed.
So that's the sauna that I use and it's 10 feet behind me right now in my office.
But it works really well and heats up really fast, but one that you like, don't worry about
all that other stuff.